.
>> THANK YOU FOR YIELDING ME
TIME.
THE TOPIC IS CANCEL CULTURE.
I HAVE SOME THOUGHTS ABOUT THAT
BUT TONIGHT, I RISE TO DISCUSS
FREEDOM AND OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
DUTY TO PROTECT IT.
MR. SPEAKER, I HAVE BEEN
PRIVILEGED TO SEE FIRSTHAND HOW
POWERFUL AND HOW FRAGILE FREEDOM
IS.
28 YEARS AGO I STOOD OUTSIDE A
POLLING PLACE, A SCHOOLHOUSE IN
WESTERN KENYA.
SOLDIERS HAD CHASED AWAY PEOPLE
WHO WERE LINED UP TO VOTE.
A FEW HOURS LATER, THEY CAME
STREAMING BACK IN.
RISKING FOR THEIR ATTACK,
UNDAUNTED IN THEIR DETERMINATION
TO EXERCISE THEIR RIGHT TO VOTE.
IN 1992 I SAT ACROSS THE TABLE
FROM A YOUNG MAYOR IN RUSSIA AND
I LISTENED TO HIM TALK OF HIS
DREAM OF LIBERATING HIS NATION
FROM COMMUNISM.
YEARS LATER, FOR HIS DEDICATION
TO THE CAUSE OF FREEDOM, BORIS
WAS ASSASSINATED BY VLADIMIR
PUTIN'S THUGS.
IN WARSAW IN 1990 I LISTENED TO
A YOUNG POLISH WOMAN TELL ME
THAT HER GREATEST FEAR WAS THAT
PEOPLE WOULD FORGET, THEY WOULD
FORGET WHAT IT WAS LIKE TO LIVE
UNDER SOVIET DOMINATION.
THAT THEY WOULD FORGET THE PRICE
OF FREEDOM.
THREE MEN, AN IMMIGRANT WHO
ESCAPED CASTRO'S REGIME, A YOUNG
MAN WHO GREW UP BEHIND THE IRON
CURTAIN AND BECAME HIS COUNTRY'S
MINISTER OF DEFENSE AND A
DISIDENT TOLD ME IT WAS THE
MIRACLE OF AMERICA CAPTURED IN
THE WORDS OF PRESIDENT RONALD
REAGAN THAT INSPIRED THEM.
AND I'VE SEEN THE POWER OF FAITH
AND FREEDOM.
I LISTENED TO POPE JOHN PAUL, II
SPOKE TO THOUSANDS IN 1985.
19 YEARS LATER, I WATCHED THAT
SAME POPE TAKE MY FATHER'S
HANDS, LOOK IN HIS EYES, AND SAY
GOOD BLESS AMERICA.
GOD HAS BLESSED AMERICA, MR.
SPEAKER.
BUT OUR FREEDOM ONLY SURVIVES IF
WE PROTECT IT.
IF WE HONOR OUR OATH, TAKEN
BEFORE GOD IN THIS CHAMBER TO
SUPPORT AND DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION.
IF WE RECOGNIZE THREATS TO
FREEDOM WHEN THEY ARISE.
TODAY WE FACE A THREAT AMERICA
HAS NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
A FORMER PRESIDENT WHO PROVOKED
A VIOLENT ATTACK ON THIS CAPITOL
IN AN EFFORT TO STEAL THE
ELECTION HAS RESUMED HIS
AGGRESSIVE EFFORT TO CONVINCE
AMERICANS THAT THE ELECTION WAS
STOLEN FROM HIM.
HE RISKS INCITING FURTHER
VIOLENCE.
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS HAVE BEEN
MISLED BY THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
THEY HAVE HEARD ONLY HIS WORDS
BUT NOT THE TRUTH AS HE
CONTINUES TO UNDERMINE OUR
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS SEWING SEEDS
OF DOUBT ABOUT WHETHER DEMOCRACY
REALLY WORKS AT ALL.
I AM A CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICAN,
AND THE MOST CONSERVATIVE OF
CONSERVATIVE PRINCE --
PRINCIPLES IS REVERENCE FOR THE
LAW.
COURTS AND MULTIPLE JUDGES THE
FORMER PRESIDENT APPOINTED HAVE
REJECTED HIS CLAIMS.
THE TRUMP DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
INVESTIGATED THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S CLAIMS OF WIDE
SPREAD FRAUD AND FOUND NO
EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT THEM.
THE ELECTION IS OVER.
THAT IS THE RULE OF LAW.
THAT IS OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
PROCESS.
THOSE WHO REFUSE TO ACCEPT THE
RULINGS OF OUR COURTS ARE AT WAR
WITH THE CONSTITUTION.
OUR DUTY IS CLEAR.
EVERY ONE OF US WHO HAS SWORN
THE OATH MUST ACT TO PREVENT THE
UNRAVELING OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT POLICY.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT PARTISANSHIP.
THIS IS ABOUT OUR DUTY AS
AMERICANS.
REMAINING SILENT AND IGNORING
THE LIE EMBOLDENS THE LIAR.
I WILL NOT PARTICIPATE IN THAT.
I WILL NOT SIT BACK AND WATCH IN
SILENCE WHILE OTHERS LEAD OUR
PARTY DOWN A PATH THAT ABANDONS
THE RULE OF LAW AND JOINS THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S CRUSADE TO
UNDERMINE OUR DEMOCRACY.
AS THE PARTY OF REGAN,
REPUBLICANS HAVE CHAMPIONED
DEMOCRACY, WON THE COLD WAR AND
DEFEATED THE SOVIET COMMUCOMMUN.
TODAY, AMERICA IS ON THE CUSP OF
ANOTHER COLD WAR THIS TIME WITH
COMMUIST CHINA.
ATTACKS AGAINST OUR DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS AND THE RULE OF LAW
EMPOWER OUR ADVERSARIES AND FEED
COMMUNISTS PROPAGANDA THAT
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY IS A FAILURE.
WE MUST SPEAK THE TRUTH.
OUR ELECTION WAS NOT STOLEN AND
AMERICA HAS NOT FAILED.
I RECEIVED A MESSAGE LAST WEEK
FROM A GOLD STAR FATHER WHO SAID
STANDING UP FOR THE TRUTH HONORS
ALL WHO GAVE ALL.
WE MUST ALL STRIVE TO BE WORTHY
OF THE SACRIFICE OF THOSE WHO
HAVE DIED FOR OUR FREEDOM.
THEY ARE THE PATRIOTS KATHRINE
LEE BAITS DESCRIBED IN THE WORDS
OF AMERICA THE BEAUTIFUL WHEN
SHE WROTE OH BEAUTIFUL FOR
HEROES PROVED IN LIBERATING
STRIFE WHO MORE THAN SELF-THEIR
COUNTRY LOVED AND MERCY MORE
THAN LIFE, ULTIMATELY MR.
SPEAKER THIS IS AT THE HEART OF
WHAT OUR OATH REQUIRES THAT WE
LOVE OUR COUNTRY MORE.
THAT WE LOVE HER SO MUCH THAT WE
WILL STAND ABOVE POLITICS TO
DEFEND HER.
THAT WE WILL DO EVERYTHING IN
OUR POWER TO PROTECT OUR
CONSTITUTION AND OUR FREEDOM
THAT HAS BEEN PAID FOR BY THE
BLOOD OF SO MANY.
WE MUST LOVE AMERICA SO MUCH
THAT WE WILL NEVER YIELD IN HE